the US House of Representatives
Judiciary Committee has issued a
subpoena demanding publication of the
Malheur report in full so far only a
redacted version has been made available
now the committee chairman said that he
could not accept a version that leaves
most of Congress in the dark here's what
he had to say about the release of the
report by the Attorney General
attorney general bar the pierced have
shown an unsettling willingness to
undermine his own department in order to
protect President Trump the malla report
outlines disturbing evidence that
President Trump engaged in obstruction
of justice and other misconduct and the
responsibility now falls to Congress to
hold the president accountable for his
actions let's get more now we're joined
by our very own Helena Humphrey who has
the latest from Washington so Helena we
just heard that statement there from the
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee what does it mean I think what
you just heard there Sarah was the
opening shot in what could be a lengthy
legal battle Jerry Nadler the chairman
of the House Judiciary Committee
confirming that he had issued a subpoena
for the full unredacted Mullah report as
well as all of the underlying documents
the Democrats now saying show me how you
reach the conclusions that you did how
you did your working out I think the
question is what specifically they are
looking for and I think their appetite
was wetted by understanding that there
are 12 criminal investigations currently
ongoing which we do not know the details
about now the Department of Justice has
until the first of May to reply to that
subpoena and they could well say no
we're not going to give you access to
for example details such as these
criminal investigations so as not to
compromise an active investigation at
which point I think the Democrats will
have to regroup and look and see what
they're trying to achieve now that the
Muller report has been delivered albeit
in redacted form and of course make
their game plan going forward into this
2020 election season so the Democrats
would want more information but we're
talking about gameplan I mean Donald
Trump himself has said that this is the
of what he calls a hoax let's get some
more on that and then we'll get your
reaction Helena game over that's what
Donald Trump tweeted after the release
in redacted form of the Miller report he
appears to think his worries are over
arriving in Florida for the Easter break
he was characteristically bullish
[Music]
Trump's advisor Kellyanne Conway said it
was case closed we're accepting
apologies today too for anybody who
feels the grace in offering them there
was no collusion and there certainly was
no criminal conspiracy with any Russians
that report makes very clear that this
White House and this president and none
of us got in their way
but Democrats say it's far from clear
that the president didn't try to
obstruct the course of justice the idea
that the report proves no obstruction is
completely at odds with hundreds of
pages in the report which document
efforts by the President to undermine
the investigation Democrats are
demanding that an unredacted version of
the report is made available to Congress
allowing them to continue the
investigation if the special counsel as
he made clear had found evidence
exonerating the president he would have
said so he did not he left that issue to
the Congress of the United States and we
will need to consider it for Trump the
Miller report is finally behind him but
the 2020 elections are looming and his
political opponents are unlikely to be
so accommodating
so Helena I mean now we have this news
from the US House Judiciary Committee
this statement how is it likely to go
down with Trump well clearly not very
well I think it's safe to say if we take
a look at the president's reaction of
course on Twitter already this morning
he's been writing that much of the
testimony in the Miller report was
little more than BS using profanity
albeit actually in full but you know he
said that these people who spoke to
Miller were quote-unquote note-takers
but the reality is that many of these
note takers in fact were key political
aides who seemingly walked Trump back
from the brink of potentially committing
a breach when it comes to the
obstruction of justice if you look at
the White House Counsel for example
McGann who did not carry through on the
request over phone two times no less for
Robert Muller to be fired if you look
for example at Jeff Sessions the former
attorney general who did not curtail the
scope of the Russia investigation simply
to look into future potential election
interference but I think it's safe to
say that now that this document has
released has been released and it's gone
from being a legal document to a
political document this fight is set to
become a far more fierce far more bitter
if you just take a look at that quote
that we heard there from Kelly and
Conway saying now today the president is
accepting apologies Helen a Humphrey in
Washington thank you